ministers have invited rail unions to
talks on Monday but seven months into
this dispute there's still no resolution
one explanation for the impasse is that
since covid the financial incentives to
do a deal have fundamentally shifted
this chart shows passenger Journeys by
quarter going back to 2019 and in the
year before covid there were 1.7 billion
Journeys on the railway that figure
collapsed in 2020 and while there's been
a recovery they're still down around a
third which means Fair revenues have
collapsed two pre-covered Revenue which
is the red bars here with a fairly
stable 12 billion pounds much higher
than the government's subsidy in blue
but income plummeted in 2020 and
subsidies Rose to keep the wheels
turning for around 7 billion to more
than 17 billion at a peak and that's why
the industry says it can't afford
inflation matching pay Rises but an
equally important change is what happens
to that Revenue under the old franchise
system fares went from passengers to
train operators they guarantee seed
Revenue to government the train
operators negotiated directly with the
unions on pay and if Network rails staff
went on strike they paid the train
companies compensation for lost fares
around 25 million pounds a day that
meant all sides had an incentive to
settle disputes if the cost of a pay
demand was less than the cost of strike
action train operators and network rail
were incentivized to do a deal but covid
ended that system today passenger fares
go directly to the Department of
Transport which then pays the train
operators to run the service but in the
event of strikes the train operators are
still getting paid the rmt say that's
cost taxpayers 340 million pounds so far
but crucially it's reduced the incentive
for a deal as all the risk all the cost
Now lies with the government and the
taxpayer now the unions know this but
they have a calculation of their own to
make everyday strike action is costing
members pay rmt Members are down 19 days
in seven months with four days coming
out of each of their December and
January pay packets that is a big hit in
a cost of living crisis so this dispute
May ultimately come down to who has the
greater appetite for financial pain
government playing with taxpayers money
or striking workers sacrificing their
own